joignable c'est l'anniversaire de julien
pot b jouera que pour ça tu le découvres
julien combes et épicurien notoire tu
lacombe et 10 812 1986 julien tu arrives
à taëf en quelle année
oh la vache je ne sais pas peut-être
fausse il ya une petite trentaine une 30
comme apte à donner moi tant d'années de
carrière un dunk arrière j'ai démarré
g53 j'ai démarré sur france 3 aquitaine
à 21
non donc tu as trente deux ans de
carrière et pose une question suivante
est ce que vous ne savez quelle est la
différence entre la carrière de maxime
gagné et la carrière de julien courbet
drôle de genre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'ado cadeaux ah bon c'est le cadeau ya
quelqu'un qui est amoureuse de la danse
a fait une petite démo je préfère
[Applaudissements]
le drapeau après un départ le drapeau
agathois tu seras au karting tu sonnes
trois fois d'accord et l'autre sans
rigoler elle se balade on dirait qu'elle
va faire les boutiques mon frère et moi
le fou et complète pour le fulham fc est
la compagne idéale à la planète il
hilare il nous faisait remarquer
complètement le faut on adore qu'est ce
qui t'arrive toits qu'il fouillait merci
julien combes et il sait que je t'aime
énormément fait des années qu'on se
connaît mais aussi tu t'amènes hormis en
bons juges du tas deux passions dans la
vie
les fenêtres et la téloche étant donné
que j'ai dit nicomaque ça n'ait pas été
validée par la chaîne c'est cadeau ah
bon ouais pareil qu'en plus maintenant
il ya un mec qui valide tout à fait
c'est à dire dès que tu payes tu dis non
c'est trop cher pour ce salon je te le
dis donc là je vais prendre une décision
or ce gars yahoo
un prime time tu fais je fais ce que tu
veux c'est le julien courbet chou
où il ya une fenêtre en or et me déplaît
couleur d'or bon on organisait un peu le
peuvent dédié de cinq ans l'a pas la
fenêtre d'ailleurs pour la montrer merci
la voilà
les mails les mecs est ce qu'on n'est
pas non mais sans déconner voilà
pourquoi travail avec un tunisien il ya
des marques de doigts sur la tête de mât
et dans quelle émission tu vois des
missions avec arthur août à des garçons
mais l'os coma se rappelle de ma mère
mais voilà pourquoi mais sans déconner
soit possible un peu ce que je qu'ils
ont oublié d'enlever la peau voilà c'est
alors voila sinon si je peux donner un
conseil gagner le printemps donc moi je
joue tu as les deux boîtes en bois tu
viens prendre et en lot il ya les
recettes
je suis à ma première idée de la doré
l'adoré julien doré
problème c'est qu'à cause de la neige je
suis venu en transports en commun je
vais devoir en train métro avec cette
fenêtre sur le bras julia ci sous la
boîte dorée dans la boîte d'oreilles et
en prime time frein prime time avant la
fin de la saison sera le julien courbet
chaud tu peux mettre qui tu veux tu veux
que je vienne faire un petit trip qui
situe les hits pas si tu veux qu'à
gâteau proulx fasse une danse tu veux
kelly de mettre la musique ça c'est pas
possible c'est le seul truc qui est pas
possible
juju est ce que tu as gagné
pour les novices qui l'on garde ayant
prime time prime français ça veut dire
prime time à venir or qui prime
lors du primeur hier tu gagneras prime
une émission et des fruits et légumes
julia
voilà
[Applaudissements]
échanges établis au moins une fois quand
ce sera votre et michou ferait que je me
suis pas une pom je ne ta vie très pas
dans la sélection de julia donc c'est
lui qui décide
jean est ce que tu as envie de changer
ou pas s'est demandé à kelly sur notre
mission alors la fois qu'il y a une
intuition c'est quelle musique je vais
mettre ça fait trente ans que je pense
sincèrement petit devrait rester sur la
tienne mais moi j'aurais pris la rose
météo luc moi je les sens un peu vicieux
je me dis qu'ils vont être dorée dans le
truck doré donc je pense que c'est le
premier là mais j'suis pas sûr
est-ce que tu as compris ce que tu veux
dire je ferai comme toi à la doré alors
et si on l'adoré la dollée
c'est ce pas rappelons que il ya un
superbe gâteau a été servi dans un
appareil à raclette
c'est la vie chère on a des vrais on
avait un gâteau celui des 30-50 bernard
montiel à travers le gâteau est
tellement mieux laframboise halal goûter
oui chérie
julien combes et je lui ai ce que
franchement après que tu fais ce que tu
veux ça fait plaisir
j'ai prouvé ces dernières années il faut
être très créatif encore l'eau je veux
bien vous trouvez une petite idée du
cher pour moi la wii u roy la raclette
ça veut dire aux proches de oui ça me
ferait plaisir passion sinon tu partiras
avec cette magnifique fenêtre ouais je
sais déjà où tu vas là m ah oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que ça passera au dessus après
35 ans de carrière oui j'ai envie de te
dire sans aucun docteur jules là je suis
fier de t'annoncer mon jugement est que
tu vas partir avec ne pas changer
non non je vois sur la durée ça
m'arrange pas pour l'argent
spectra la voiture est sûre à dori enfin
sur la torre bon jeu où tu pars avec
[Applaudissements]
sauf lui
je
[Applaudissements]